being able to navigate
is an extraordinary gift and there is
nothing like it in the world
i get no more sense of satisfaction
greater
than leaving a port and
knowing that i can get my team
and my boat safely from that port to
another port maybe three
four five six thousand miles away
being at sea for me is its total freedom
and it is the ultimate opportunity
to be you because you can't be anything
else you you
are naked in front of your peers on a
boat it is a small area
maiden is 58 feet long there's 12 women
in a 58 feet boat i mean you are
literally up against each other
and so you have to be you the
greatest moment for me when i'm sailing
is the moment that the land
disappears it's an indescribable moment
of adventure and
no turning back and just you and the
boat
and the elements and i wish everyone
could experience this at least
once in their lives the further you get
away from land
the more you kind of fit into yourself
it is you
how do we get to the next place how do
we stay alive
how do we look after each other um and
what do we do
to get to the other side so the question
i get
asked the most when i go and do talks is
how do you become an ocean racing sailor
and that's a really good question and
i've always wanted to say
i had a vision which became a dream
which became an obsession
but of course life's not like that and
one thing i'm really
anxious for people to know about me is
that my life hasn't gone from a to b
because how many people can say their
lives just go from a to b
they think i'm going to do this and and
they go and do it
so i tell the truth and the truth is
that i was expelled from school when i
was 15 years old and
my long-suffering headmaster sent along
a long-suffering note to my
long-suffering mother basically saying
if
tracy darkens the doors of the school
again then we will call the police and
my mum looked at me and she said darling
education is not for everyone and then
she gave me the best piece of advice
anyone ever has given me
she said every single one of us is good
at something
you just have to go and find what that
is and at the age of 16
she let me go backpacking off to greece
i ended up working on boats
um which was okay 17 years old didn't
really know what i want to do
kind of going with the flow and then on
my second transatlantic
my skipper said to me can you navigate
and i said of course i can't navigate i
was expelled before long division
he said well don't you think you should
be able to navigate you know what
happens if i fall over the side
stop being a bystander in your own life
stop looking at what you're doing
and start taking part this day for me
was the day that my whole life started i
learned to navigate in two days
and this is someone who hates numbers
and sees them as hieroglyphics
it opens up avenues and opportunities to
me that i could never have imagined
i actually managed to get a ride on a
whitbread round the world race boat it
was with 17 south african men
and me i was 21 years old and it was the
longest nine months of my life but
i went as a cook i managed to survive
until the end and when i got to the end
of this race i realized that there were
230
crew in this race and three women and i
was one of them
and i'm a lousy cook i'm a really good
navigator
i think the second most profound thought
in my entire life was
no man is ever going to allow me to be a
navigator
on their boat ever and that is still the
case today
in 35 years of the whitbread there's
only been two female navigators that
haven't been on all female cruise and
that's how maiden was born
that was the moment i thought i've got
something to fight for and i
i had no idea that i wanted to have this
fight and
it was something um that i took to like
a duck to water
it i discovered things about myself that
i had no idea existed
i discovered i had a fighting spirit i
discovered i was competitive
never knew that before and i discovered
my second passion which was equality
i couldn't let this one lie and it
became not just about me wanting to
navigate on a boat and having to put my
own
crew together in my own team raise my
own money find my own boat
so that i could be a navigator this was
about women everywhere and this was when
i realized that this was probably what i
was going to spend the rest of my life
doing
it took ages for us to find the monies
to the 1989 whip bread around the world
race and as we looked at all the
big multi-million pound um all-male
projects around us with their brand new
shiny boats you know designed for the
race we realized
this was not going to be us you know we
had to make this up as we went along no
one had enough faith in us to give us
this kind of money
so i mortgaged my house and uh we found
an old wreck
with a pedigree an old whitbread boat
who'd already been around the world
twice
in south africa we somehow persuaded
some guy to put her on a ship and bring
her back to the uk
uh for us the girls were horrified at
the state
of the boat we got a free place in the
yard we got her up on the hard
and we redesigned her we ripped her
apart
we did all the work ourselves it was the
first time that anyone had ever seen
women
in a shipyard so that was quite
entertaining every morning when we would
walk in
everyone just gawk at us but it also had
its advantages because
everyone was so helpful we were such a
novelty
um you know we got given a generator an
engine
do you want this whole rope yep old
sales yep we'll have those
um so we we really made it up as we went
along and i think
actually one of the huge advantages that
we had was um
you know there was no preconceived idea
about how an all-female crew
would sail around the world so whatever
we did was okay
and what it also did was it drew people
to
it not just women men anyone who'd ever
been told you can't
do something because you're not good
enough you're right gender or right race
or right color or whatever
maiden became a passion um and
it was hard to raise the money um
hundreds of companies wouldn't sponsor
us they told us
that we couldn't do it people thought we
were going to die um
you know guys would literally come up to
me and say you're going to die
i think well okay that's my business
it's not yours
in the end king hussein of jordan
sponsored maiden and
that was an amazing thing way ahead of
his time all about equality
we sailed around the world with a
message of peace and equality we were
the only boat on the race with
a message of any kind we won two legs of
the whitbread
two of the most difficult legs and we
came second overall and that is still
the best result for a british boat
since 1977. it annoyed a lot of people
and i think what it did at the time we
didn't realize you know we crossed the
finishing line this incredible finish
600 boats sailing up the stone with us
50 000 people in ocean village chanting
made and
made um as we sailed in and so we knew
we'd done something that we wanted to do
and we hoped we'd achieved
something good but we have no idea at
the time
how many women's lives we changed
the southern ocean is my favorite ocean
each ocean has a character
so the north atlantic is a jumping ocean
it's a jolly go for it heave-ho
type of have fun type of ocean the
southern ocean
is a deadly serious ocean and you
know when the moment you cross into the
southern ocean the last tune and
longitude
you know when you're there the waves
have been building
they start getting big white caps on the
top it becomes really great you start to
get sensory deprivation
it is very focused on who you
are and what you are with this massive
wilderness
around you it is empty it is so
big and so empty you see albatrosses
swirling around the boat it takes about
four days to sail through their
territory
so you have the same albatross for four
days and they find us quite an oddity
so they literally wind surf off the the
wind that comes off the mainsail and
they hang
behind the boat and you sort of feel
this presence behind you you turn around
and this is albatross just looking at
you
we sold maiden at the end of the race uh
we still have no money
uh and five years ago we found her at
the same time as a film director decided
he wanted to make a documentary about
maiden we found mate and she burst back
into my life and reminded me
a lot of things i've forgotten actually
over the years
about following my heart and my gut and
really being part of the universe and
everything
i find important in life maiden has
given back to me again
we rescued her we did a crowdfunder we
rescued her from the seychelles
princess hire king hussein's daughter
funded the shipping back to the uk
and then the restoration all the
original crew were involved we put the
original team back together
and then we decided what are we going to
do with maiden and this for me
really was the moment of my life where i
looked back on every single thing that
i'd done every project
every feeling every passion every battle
every fight
and i decided that i wanted maiden to
continue that fight for the next
generation
maiden is sailing around the world a
five-year world tour
we are engaging with thousands of girls
all over the world
we are supporting community programs
that get girls into education
education doesn't just mean sitting in a
classroom
this for me is about teaching girls you
don't
have to look a certain way you don't
have to feel a certain way
you don't have to behave a certain way
you can be successful you can follow
your dreams and you can fight for them
life doesn't go from a to b it's messy
my life has been
a mess from beginning to end but somehow
i've got
to where we're going the future for us
and maiden
looks amazing and for me
it is all about closing the circle it's
about closing the circle with maiden
and using her to tell girls that if just
one person believes in you
you can do anything
you